Congress faces a very busy new year
after putting some major decisions until
after the holidays they put them off
lawmakers did pass a temporary spending
bill to keep the government running
through January 19th it includes
short-term funding for the Children's
Health Insurance Program or chip as it's
called and extends authorization of the
government's warrantless surveillance
program a measure adding eighty 1
billion dollars in disaster aid for
hurricane and wildfire victims past the
house but it did stall in the Senate
Congress returns January 3rd CBS News
chief Washington correspondent Face the
Nation anchor John Dickerson is with us
good morning lots to talk about first
once again Congress punting on this
spending bill yeah that's right nobody
was gonna have a showdown right before
Christmas but this has caused tension in
both parties because these spending
bills are the way you use leverage to
get done what you want to get done so
now all of that leverage in fighting and
doing and throwing including a lot of
promises that were made to get the tax
cut bill passed those are all bottled up
for when this comes up again in January
tax cuts the big achievement going into
the new year how well has this how well
as the GOP and the president who control
Congress positioned themselves for the
midterms at this point well you know
it's interesting the president's got a
lot of achievements the Republicans can
point to things I mean the presidents
got achievements and lowering
regulations on judicial nominations and
all of that but if you look at his
approval ratings I mean they are at
historically low levels the Republican
Party's approvals are low the hope among
Republicans is that with this tax cut
bill that will improve but the support
for the tax cut bill is in some polls
under 30% so they position themselves
extremely well with their base of their
party but the question is how big is
that and how will that term pay off in
the off year election and will they
turnout and by the way there's a lot to
happen between now and Election Day well
the election of doug jones changed the
game a little bit in alabama made the
race a little tighter 51 to 49
so what issues do you think Mitch
McConnell needs to focus on well it will
be tougher for him it's gonna be tougher
because getting 60 votes from Democrats
if you look at what Democrats are seeing
in their base it's they're seeing that
their their dislike of Donald Trump is
keeping that base riled up so why would
you give Donald Trump a win that's the
way the Democrat now on the other hand
what the Republicans will try and do on
an issue like infrastructure is take an
issue that's broadly
among Democrats and say here you go we
want to put something on infrastructure
through the Congress will you join with
us and that would be an interesting
early battle but in addition to
infrastructure you've got this question
of entitlements Paul Ryan wants to get
to it you've got a big deficit problem
caused by the tax bill but Mitch
McConnell says we're not going to do it
president has said he's not going to
touch Medicare and Social Security they
don't even like calling them
entitlements so if that really gets
joined it'll be a tough fight I don't
want to miss what happened in the
General Assembly essentially the world
denouncing the Trump administration's
recognition recognition of Jerusalem as
Israel's capital how does this play out
as the as the u.s. looks to the world
for help on North Korea and Iran and
cooperation on other issues that's right
you have this very there's a disconnect
between on the one hand saying we're
taking names we affirm America first and
yet then when the president even when he
spoke at the UN saying you know this
that using the body to create a world
pressure on North Korea and also using
the body to say to China you know you
want to be a it's part of the way
they're putting pressure on China say
you want to be a player on the world
stage you will gain favor on the world
stage by helping us with North Korea so
you have to believe in the notion of a
world stage in the notion of collective
views from other countries so on the one
hand you need that to exist and then on
the other you say we're gonna take names
if you if you disapprove of what we're
doing there is a disconnect to there but
there's often been a disconnect between
the way the u.s. uses the UN and then
when it wants to do what it does and
doesn't like what the UN is telling it
they say well we're gonna go our own way
you and I best or nikki Haley was very
firm yesterday yeah alone yeah John
thank you so much Sunday on Face the
Nation John and a roundtable of CBS news
correspondents will review all the big
stories from this year and look ahead to
next year's elections that's gonna be
Sunday right here on CBS Christmas Eve
John Dickerson is working that's
wrapping presents under the watch will
be watching